This is FRESH AIR I'm Terry Gross. My guest Jennifer Lawrence is starring in two
new films the fourth and final installment of the action series The Hunger Games
and the new film
Joy Joy is Lawrence's third film directed by David O. Russell all
three Joy Silver Linings Playbook an American Hustle also starred Bradley
Cooper and Robert De Niro.
Lawrence won the Best Actress Oscar for Silver Linings Playbook. She was nominated for Oscars
for American Hustle and her breakthrough role in the independent film Winter's Bone.
Joy is a comic drama loosely based on the story of joy Mangano who invented
the miracle mop and other household objects and became known not only for her inventions.
But for her sales pitches on Q V C and the Home Shopping
Network in the film before Joy is a successful business woman
she's lost her mother is so depressed she stays in bed watching soap
operas her father played by Deniro is temporarily sharing the basement with
Joy's ex-husband.
Nobody's getting along and joy is having trouble supporting her two young
children when she invents a mop that is self wringing so that you don't hurt
your hands wringing it out she can't find anyone to sell it until she goes to Q B
C and meets with an exact played by Bradley Cooper. He likes the mop and gets
one of Q.V. sees best on air pitchman to sell it on
air but that guy botches the on air demonstration and no one buys the
mop in this scene joy arrives at Kew B.C. unannounced and corners
the Bradley Cooper character trying to get a second chance.
Amid a meeting with the leaders.
Go home and watch the numbers on television.
Thanks fifty thousand
moms borrowing and owing every dollar including your home.
It could have been a better. The tide of another show. I don't. One time
or anyone else to try it should be me.
We don't have celebrities was most of the
selling us who showed you
some who sold it to you who taught you how to use it and who convinced you that it was
great to you thought it was worthless. She was missing gifts.
That's a scene from Joy Jennifer Lawrence welcome to FRESH AIR As part of
your preparation for the film did you try out the miracle mop the self
or any miracle
mop. I did not I probably should have i can i did
i always I did I did mom but
I didn't have a miracle I have a sponge and so did mom and then there was a mop in
my trailer. So I would practice that you know practice like technique
and just kind of getting getting used to it and there were so many miracle mop on
set I would start working them and I'm like really just trying to study because the amazing thing about joy a lot of people
have and pensions are they have ideas and they bring it to somebody else and say I have this idea I
don't know how to make it but Joy grew up in
a metal garage so she was in complete control of all of her creations on this
is how I wanted to be made which is very different than just having an idea so
I studied the model more to just try to understand some of these
mind peeling back and looking at each you know how would you think this clipping out of this and then
a cop pulled in here and
then all of that fascinated me so I dealt with the mob but when I first showed Bradley Cooper in the showroom.
The mommy watched me and I was like no no no that's not how you mob and he showed me how
to properly. Read the Bradley Cooper actually used the miracle mob
when he was in college he did his
mom watched T.V. see every day they always keep easy boxes in the house and he knew all about
that world and I knew nothing and I had an O.C.D. mom. So
she would always give us some stories and tell us what to do but she couldn't
actually live with it being done the wrong way. It never actually mattered you'd always end up doing
it. So one of
the trademarks of David Russell's movies particularly the trilogy that you're in
Silver Linings Playbook American Hustle and
joy is that they're very kinetic there's always movement happening like
characters walking in and out of the frame like scene just kind of blend into
another and I'm wondering how aware you are of
that when you're on camera and the film is being shot do you have any sense of what it's
going to look like how it's going to be edited how kinetic it's going to
be no and it's such a
great
thing that you know every time you do a movie scary because you can read a script
and say I love the script. This is great costar this movie is going to be great but
you don't really have control over it you know you can walk onto a set and you like the set
it's terrible you know you start watching the director and you don't have any
control but with David I have a thousand percent trust. So
I all I do is focus on my performance as until seeing the movie that I see
an amazing camera move. That he did you know are Notice that Eastern Airlines like Zoom Zoom in past all of
the people or something like that on the day I don't I don't pay attention
to any of
it one of the things he does not like to do is to say cut.
So from your perspective as an actor in his film. What difference does it
make whether he's yelling cut or not.
I don't know I've never really particularly noticed I'm not really calling. I mean I think that he
likes everybody refers to his sets you know everybody everybody says the same thing that it's crazy it's
hectic you know I've said it too it's a tactic. It's just not you know but I think
that there's a real
specificity that we just don't really realize that he's doing all of
that on purpose he wants all of the energy translated and on the scene in
the movie he wants everybody on their feet every. It's on their toes you never know when the camera's going to move and
be on you so you are in the scene. The whole time of the cameras I mean the real movie is watching the camera
guys try to keep up with all this there's a little white
guy was. You know like a light on a stick and they're just running around trying to do and
get everything so when you call
cut and everything stops everything
dies and the whole action and then you have to get started up again I think
probably just trying to keep momentum and keep the energy up and keep people on their toes.
How many takes do you like to do when you're shooting a scene and how does that compare say with Robert De
Niro who who you've worked with on. Other films with David O.
Russell. I've never noticed.
Bob feeling one way or the other about about
takes David doesn't really do a lot of takes you know the first time I did the Q.B.
see her first time on camera you know and there was a. I had to quickly
memorize this monologue I didn't really know that I was going to do it which is my fault I don't
really pay attention to what I was doing when I came into work and I was trying to
memorize it and David did a whole three sixty shot around my head of there was a cut move on and I was like oh my god.
Please please let me have another one I think it depends completely on the scene because
sometimes I feel like it dies. You know after especially with
emotional scenes.
It's fresh two maybe three times and then you just lose the feeling like
that adrenaline just kind of goes away and then you're just copying what you were doing before which is
fine because it's necessary and part of the job. Sometimes it's dialogue.
It's not until the tenth or eleventh time and all this and you start hearing it you're like oh that's what I'm saying
so it's really just a pan.
So the first movie that you made with David O. Russell with Silver Linings Playbook.
You won an Oscar for your role in that. So I want to play a scene
from that Bradley Cooper play someone who has bipolar disorder he gets out of a mental
facility mental health facility at the beginning of the film.
He's obsessed with. Adding back with his wife who has left him in the meantime you play his best
friend sister in law. You're a young widow who has your own mental health
issues but you get him you understand him and you've enlisted him to
be your partner in a dance
competition but one day he doesn't show up for rehearsal because his father played by Deniro needs
him at the Eagles game. The father is a bookmaker and he's got a lot of money riding on this game
but Cooper gets into a fight at a tailgate party never makes it into the stadium when the Eagles lose
the father blames Bradley Cooper's character for the loss and for bringing bad
luck and he's blaming you too for bringing bad luck because you
think he thinks you're taking up too much of Bradley Cooper stime So this tape scene takes
place at the home of the Bradley Cooper and Robert De Niro characters their family
after the game after the Eagles
lose and you walk in and Deniro tells you
that the bad luck is basically your fault.
Ever since ever since he was with you ever since you think that I'm why today is out. That's
right you why why the reason why today happened. I think so let's talk about
that be my guest the first night the Patten I met at my sister's The Eagles beat the
forty nine ers handily forty to twenty six.
The second time we got together we went for a run and the Phillies beat the daughters seven to five and L.C.S..
The next time we went for a run the Eagles beat the Falcons twenty seven to
fourteen the third time we got together we had Raisin Bran in the diner and the
Phillies dominated Tampa Bay in the fourth game of the World Series tended to.
Well one I think about when the Eagles beat the Seahawks fourteen to seven it was with you he was with me.
We went for a run and there have been no games since Pat and I have been rehearsing every
day and a padded been with me like he was supposed to he would have gotten a fight he
wouldn't be in trouble. Maybe he'll be the New
York Giants. Since But it's all written
all girls.
That's Jennifer Lawrence in a scene from Silver Linings Playbook. David O. Russell sometimes
gives actors music to listen to to help set the mood and he give a new music to listen to for
you for your
roles.
A little bit. That's not we normally start arguing
about that though I always think it's annoying but it's necessary but I was
asleep one time we were flying to New York together and I was fast asleep on the flight
and all of us on there was an
ear bud Shot tonight. From Raging Bull as I crossed.
So it's basically everything that David and I argue about on the day that I think is
unnecessary David I don't want to talk about the thing I don't want you to go through the whole movie with me like I know what
the movie is about let's go oh I don't want to listen to
this song when I see the movie and I see what he's doing and I always put everything together.
I'm always wrong it will always change something in some way that I didn't
know you know in silver linings and proudly and I are at a diner and I'm talking about
how I got fired from work by having sex with everybody in the office.
I had read the scene one way. Bradley and I had both read it a certain way were doing the scene and then David
told us to do the entire thing and slow motion what seemed like a
crazy note and we did and that is the
scene that that's the take they ended up using it looks phenomenal. I felt so weird
and you know I questioned. I think on the next i'll finally stop questioning
him. So what was the difference between the way you were doing it in the slow motion in terms of
the meaning it gave you that scene.
I was just doing it very matter of fact you know this is what happened I you know so I
had sex with everybody in the office and then I got fired and you know so then I sued them for sexual harassment just kind
of how somebody would discuss over dinner. How you got fired from your job
without really any feeling in it you know just kind of yeah that's
happened. And when he told me to do it in slow motion I
realized I was to do
thing. Bradley And
that changed the whole meaning of that scene in the moment.
Because And then that made complete sense because of course of course you would be you're probably doing
that probably seduce people without even knowing that she's doing it that's where her comfort lies
is being found sex
even people. How did you get the role of Katniss in The Hunger Games. What did you have to
do in the audition. Did you have to show off your use of a bow and arrow.
I didn't know that came after the job.
I auditioned I auditioned with the scene after I've
been chosen after I volunteer and I have to say goodbye to my
family and scene with Pete out in the cave. When his leg
is
hurt. Yeah I auditioned
and director cried which I took as a
good sign and then I left
and they offered it to me I really wanted it really badly.
I love the books I love the idea of it and then when they offered it to
me I took a few days before saying yes which an executive
told me later he thought it was a negotiating move
and it really hit me what a huge decision it was it
was such a. You know Twilight has come out and we had seen how big
those were and how instant that was and I had really you know kind of done Indies
and I just thought it needed more thought you know yes or
no question very rarely changes your entire life just saying yes to something
so I just thought it needed some thought so I thought about it for a few days and I said yes I'm very
happy I did what was the
thought process like when you were weighing the pros and cons of saying yes. What were some of
the things in each
column.
I would go you know if I was sitting I remember sitting with. Friend eating and I was
just wondering you know what was going to be like a year from now those movies come out my having and I want to be
able to do
this my parents' house when I go home like.
That's not private our neighbors going to you know when I was right about all of these things my parents did eventually have
to move. I was just thinking about fame really and also just kind
of my future I don't know if men do this but as a woman I've always imagined
being a mother
and I've always loved acting but I didn't think it
would take up a huge part of my life I I thought you know I'll act I'll do some
movies because I really love it and I was so happy I was originally just on a sitcom and I was happy
to just stay on the set
forever. And so I was kind of a little bit more casual about acting
and it was more kind of focused on of my future kind of as a human and being a mom
and I don't know what would that be like being a super incredibly
famous person
and how would that affect everything in my future. I just wanted to just think
about it.
And so when you decided to say yes we did you feel resigned to
the downside of
theme.
A little bit. I mostly just kind of said you know what I love this character I
love this movie I believe in it and I'm going to say yes for the same reasons that I would say yes to any
Andy and
then but I was still afraid of those things but I remember there was a moment when I was on set under games and I
was thinking about my life and I was like you know what
I don't like going out. I'm talking total homebody. I'm always
looking for excuses not to go out I was like I'm actually probably built for this. So I
can now use fame as an excuse I can't go there into
fame and I do. I don't think I've ever heard
that before that it's a great and you wouldn't you go well you know if we had each
other's numbers I'd be like Man I
gotta come over here and we'll drink wine I'm too
famous to go to that right.
So. I know a little bit about a bow and arrow because when I was in summer
camp we were taught archery So I feel like I'm qualified
to be so qualified to ask you what was it like to learn how to become
a master Archer. It was really cool.
I really really enjoyed archery I had an amazing and struck her to
know she was Georgian she was an excellent instructor
very strict you know if I had bad form she'd pinch my ear. She
would generally put up with anything and it totally changed my body it was so
crazy when I went back for the fitting for the second movie for Catching Fire my shoulders were two
inches broader my right arm is one inch longer than my left
arm permanently I
guess but I really enjoy it. She should actually punch your ear if you did
something wrong not punch it pinch it open shit. Sorry God I'm happy we straighten that
out she punched me and I had a great. So
what was one of
the worst things you had to put yourself through in making the Hunger Games movies.
In durance was you know you really have to get in shape just to be able to film those movies
because whatever I'm doing whatever you
see whatever action sequences it's running fighting whatever it is you know that's we're doing that for twelve hours a day or
more the water stuff is very tricky and catching fire all of the
water stuff was done and November and December in Atlanta in freezing cold water
so it's just a horrible feeling when you're shivering when you're dry and then have to dive into freezing cold water is
just the
worst and I perforated my eardrum doing a water
stand when I had to jump in the water the jet perforated at your job and I'm an
idiot so you know I couldn't hear for three days and I was like I don't have to go to the doctor and now I have like a
permanent
ear problems. Can you hear that here. I can hear fine it gets a little painful
sometimes when flying. Overall I'm totally OK and don't need to be. Whining about
it you mention fire I
mean one of the things your character does is where like a
flaming flaming costume an address that.
Breaks into flames when you twirl like
what magicians use.
It was all C.G. The only real fire we really owe. Why did I think was on the
first the
first movie I had to run through a trail there were fire balls being fired at me and
so these trees would ignite and fire and so they would mark the trees and mark
a path run through here you'll be safe these trees are going to
explode and he starts running and all the trees start exploding you can't see the tape
anymore so I'm right. I have no idea what tree is going to explode. It was the
scariest thing I've ever done to my darling because I was really running through a forest of exploding trees with
fire and somebody made a video of it and I was just like how on earth did they insure
me to do that. So what kind of
precautions do you insist on when you're doing a film like that safety precautions.
None really. I always just kind of assume by the time I'm there they figured it out.
There are some things and harness
work that I don't know scares me of the what it was like these bans that push
against what I assume would be like my female organ area and I'm just
like now this doesn't seem right to be hanging from this is this much pressure for hours
I put my foot down about that the other day at work I was like I have to be able to have children one day I don't
know what you're getting from my uterus for
four This is FRESH AIR I'm Terry
Gross back with Jennifer Lawrence she stars in the new film joy which is one of
three films along with Silver Linings Playbook an American
Hustle that she's made with director David O. Russell Lawrence is also starring in
The Hunger Games films the fourth and final episode is currently in theaters.
As a woman who is now an action star and in addition to being in. The movie star.
What are some of the things that viewers project onto you in your
action star
persona.
You mean like project on to me and my personal life yeah. I don't know I feel like if I go to a
spinning class oh my God I better
I can't quit. Everyone's like. Katniss
sucked out I don't know I don't
know the X. I mean I think that there's you're always aware of this of the celebrity in
general that there can be one moment you know I always hear my friends and
family will tell a story about a celebrity. I don't think they're very nice because they were
offered popcorn and they said you know I'm not a big fan
of popcorn is like who doesn't like popcorn. I don't think I like them anymore and I'm like
Oh God. Like well how many things have I said
like it's amazing how you celebrities there's this some
bizarre thing where like you say one thing you do one thing you know what if you don't know a
person how you can judge that your entire being based on you know
one thing that you've said it's a huge amount of pressure.
Your breakthrough role was in Winter's Bone an independent film and you
played a teenage girl in the Ozark Mountains where there isn't much work except cooking
and selling
meth which your character's father and his friends do but your father's arrested
he puts up the house for Bale then skips town. So unless you can track him down
your family which is already pretty poor is going to lose their house which is
basically all your family
has so you're going around talking to all your father's friends trying to figure out
where is he so I want to play a scene in which you're knocking on the door of one of the leaders
of this meth ring and that guy's wife answers the door.
You
got the wrong
life. She Bay
Marie my dad's Jessup Dolly.
Oh
yeah here for trouble are
you. You know my name is one of my nephews is Buster Leavell And didn't
he shoot your dad I want
to yes so that I got enough and it was
me I settled up there so nothing.
She didn't like I said
only what is it you want. I got a
real bad need to talk with
them and got no need talk to you.
But I need to I really really got to ma'am
please. Some of our blood at least is the
same thing that supposed to mean something and that what is always
said
and you got no man could do
this. Oh man I don't know I guess Jennifer
Lawrence in the scene from Winter's Bone. So for this part you
were told you were too pretty. So what did you do to change that so you
could get the part.
Well
they turned me down and then they moved casting to New
York and I put myself on a red eye to just show
up to casting the next day in New
York. So that always helps right
I not showering no
makeup eventually they went
oh she's right. She's not you you grew up in Kentucky
near Louisville in Louisville in
Louisville and. In school we were US legit because you've done such athletic
things for The Hunger Games. Yeah our parents had a rule we all had to be in
sports. So I played softball basketball as a
cheerleader. And field hockey. Did you enjoy
it you know. Not at all I did team sports.
Why I
don't like being I have always done things I agree about being and I heard.
I felt that way in school I even felt that way and field trips I was like oh felt
like cattle or something I don't know I just wanted to
break free he pays individual. So I don't know there was something about
team sports classes. I didn't take well to I didn't like it did you
like solo sport.
Yeah eventually when I started learning or learning archery I really enjoyed that you know with archery you can
see yourself as you practice getting closer and closer to the
target and it's just between you and your eyes and your shoulder blades.
And your aim and you know it's just between you and the bow and I
enjoy
that what got you interested in acting and in taking it seriously.
Just loving it.
I did an indie called the Poker House and between the hiatus
from my sitcom and I did burning plane and and I did Winter's
Bone also all night as for the sitcom when I first got on a sitcom like I said I was like
I'm good. Lucille Ball I can be on a sitcom for the rest of my life is
great and. Then I fell in love.
I fell in love with a film I loved.
It's really so much about just pure acting with me I mean even when I'm when I
have time off I just really miss acting so my love for acting turned in to doing
more movies and then that turned into a whole business side of things that you know I'm
still pretty overwhelmed by figuring out the business of all of that.
When you were fourteen you went to New York in the hopes of. Doing roles they did when your parents go
with you.
My mom was with me for when we went for spring break that was just going to be like a little
trip. That we were going out together and
then I ended up getting just go over to Union
Square and I talked about it every single day talked about acting and.
Every single day when we went back to Kentucky and eventually it was just like I'm leaving and I had saved up
enough babysitting money and I was like I'm going. So they tried to find a nice balance
between me kind of running away and being completely
unsafe having a little bit of supervision so I had a horrible apartment that was completely rat infested.
Thank you New York. Gone. New York and my brother when we was eighteen went with me
at first and my parents left us and we're both like we're going to
die and then a girl who worked at my mom my parents' children's
camp came out watch me for a little bit and I just kind of tradeoff
eventually my mom saw how happy I was No I didn't
have anxiety anymore I didn't have all of these things that I had when I was in
school unhappy. I was so happy that it's I think it was kind of hard for
her as a mother to send her back.
Really I think it was also just kind of some sort
of maternal instinct that she knew it was the right thing to do which I'm so grateful for to this day.
Well kind of anxiety Did you have.
I don't know I just like. I was I remember just always feeling
exhausted when I was at school and I think about it now
wondering what that is I don't know if
that's actors. I work with an actor who always says Actors are
chameleons you know even if you don't really
realize your depth and the kind of everyone the air around which I don't feel that way really about my
personality I don't really feel like I change who I am depending on who I'm with
but I think you feel a lot of things the only way to do an emotional scene
is to feel empathy for your character to think.
That character is going through and really open up and feel it and now that I know
what that is and that's my job and I can channel that I can understand that feeling understand when
somebody's telling me a story that's really sad and I feel like I can feel it. I know that that's
just it's
just normal for me now but as a kid I think by the time we get to lunch I was so
exhausted I think I was around a hundred kids feeling every single thing I don't really
know I've tried to figure it out maybe just. I mean I guess the simple answer would be social
anxiety that kind of fits into you know wanting to go out even now.
Like wanting to yeah oh
yeah I don't like being around but I get overwhelmed my favorite thing. I
much prefer
just small circles of people who I actually want to be around to actually want to talk
to and being able to just be you know like when you're out and you've got to spend your whole
night going thank you oh my God Yeah I think like I look at people. My parents my age
now every get married my friends are getting
married and I'm like. You want to spend your whole night going thanks thank you thank you for
coming thank you so much you know it seems like a nightmare. Seems like award
season. So you know being an apartment and age fourteen
that had rats. I wouldn't be able to go to sleep at night. How
how do you know
it's night was horrible that's when they all come out it was you know the bathroom and I
just really wanted to that my dad still talks about that he said that's when I knew you were
serious that's when I think that that was the turning point for my
dad letting me do this as he came and saw all the conditions I was living in you know
no water there was no kitchen like a closet with a hot
plate and I got to the point where I was literally to sharing food
with sake I would to Chinatown that's where I got most everything you're doing where you did it and you know I
don't really have any
money so like a rat eaten my loaf of bread you know before when I first got there I'd be
like you and throw the whole loaf of bread away but eventually I was like I could be able for bread. So I started
just cutting around the whole
the. You know it's got a very literally sharing food with a rat.
So that's what my parents were like Yeah I think
she really really wants to do this so do they help you out financially.
Eventually we moved to L.A. we got in our
car from Kentucky and we drove to L.A. and that's when I got on the sitcom and they didn't need to support me
financially anymore.
So you mentioned you were discovered in New York in Union Square tells the
discovery
story. I was watching street dancing and some man named
Daniel I believe same said I am a model scout can I take
your picture and I was like oh well yeah i'll my
brothers always talked about all ugly I was that was a shock.
So I let him take my picture and you know my mom and I didn't know that any of this was creepy we were just from Kentucky.
It wasn't an end up being creepy but that it could potentially be creepy and so she gave
him her number and he called the next day and said oh you know all these modeling agencies want to meet
with her and we didn't have anything else to do in New York so we went to the meetings
and then somewhere in there I read my first script and I just I
knew. Your brother used to tell you you were ugly.
Yeah you know they were brothers they used to call me before you know
the boots. Do you know. And yeah but it didn't I didn't care it didn't matter
I feel like I have a daughter one day and she has made she's pretty I'm just going to like my didn't matter.
I never never grew up with that ever. It didn't really matter to me. Yeah I like your
answer why does it matter I think it's good you know that matter. Yeah yeah they were
I remember one time crying because these girls at school left me out they were every was going to the movies
and they did invite me
and my mom tried to comfort me and they just they're just jealous of you my
brother walks and I
goes Don't tell her that they really don't like her because she's I don't ever think you guys don't ever
think somebody doesn't like you because you're
jealous. My grandmother yesterday. Because they're jealous and I knew I knew
that was not it I know it's such a really like an
annoying. I don't really know that's a very good lesson to teach somebody I think yeah look at yourself if you
feel like somebody doesn't like you think back. There's only you could have done. Could you have offended them. I
don't think I should just go oh you're just jealous like why would you raise your
kids. Like my mom bless her heart you know this is what moms are for and I'm probably
gonna do the same thing when I'm a mother you know when we're watching Joy and then I forgot that the singing part comes on
and I'm like
oh my God Oh my God I put my hand on my hand like I can't watch
it and my mom listen because you are the best singer in the entire world you are the greatest singer
in the whole world and it's just very So we. But I but
that's just not true.
So you said a couple of things. A couple of big public statements that have actually
made news. I want to ask you about what you said after the Sony hack.
And when a lot of
Sony emails. People executives who work at Sony a lot of their e-mails were made public and through
those e-mails you learned that men you worked with on movies were getting paid much more for
those movies than you were. And you attributed it to a gender double standard and you
wrote about
it in Lena Dunham's publication Lenny wrote I didn't
get mad at Sony I got mad at
myself I failed as a negotiator because I gave up early I didn't want to
keep fighting for millions of dollars that frankly due to franchises. I don't
need parentheses. I told you this wasn't relatable don't hate me and
you
wrote but if I'm honest with myself I would be lying if I didn't say there was an element of wanting
to be liked that influence my decision to close the deal without a real fight. I didn't
want to seem difficult or
spoiled and then you say you realize from the hack that quote every man I was working
with Definitely didn't worry about
being difficult or spoiled. So how did you
decide to say that in
public
I was aware of. Any quality of the you know twenty one
percent General pay gap between men and women and
and you know when that happened and I and I saw those
numbers.
I really didn't look at that and say something unfair was done to me I think that that's very
possible that you know we're talking
about this gender bias that
also exists in us as women. So
we are very possible as individuals are doing this to
ourselves that we have.
A historical global reputation
that isn't being a baller or a bad ass or being
aggressive you know that's not an
attractive to do those things but more than that you know but that was really the pay gap the
pay gap and why I wanted to discuss it was because I was like
if I'm having these feelings and I it's my own kind
of mentality that's getting in my own way and
the statistics are an arguable. Maybe I'm not the only woman
who feels this
way and I figured if I had a voice I should use it in case there are
other women out there that that are not getting paid or not asking for
money the way that they should be because of
the same kind of relatable feelings that I was having so did that
affect your
ability to equalize the playing field financially.
I'm still working on it you know I wish that I could say I wrote it and then and then boom the problem was
fixed but that's just not true I was writing about a very
true problem that I have you know I'm still struggling with
it. How did you start thinking this way did you always think this way.
Is this kind of thing came recently to you.
I
think I've always been outspoken and opinionated.
But growing up and learning
more I'm talking specifically about just thinking in terms of gender about what gender equality
gender is now and it was reset was getting and it was getting into
the world of commerce it was getting and you know having a.
Having a
power on that and
not wanting to use it or not wanting to recognize it because I always I just want to
be likeable I just wanna be likable and then realizing you just get screwed
over so I think it just came developed over time
from from working because I I was I was saying yes to
these things and doing overtime for free and all this stuff because I wanted to be like
just seemed ridiculous and I didn't meet one actor who would do the same I don't mean one male actor who did the
same thing.
After your i Cloud account was hacked and naked pictures of you were posted.
You called it a sexual violation and you said anybody who looked
at those pictures you're perpetuating a sexual offense. You should cower
with
shame you were quoted as saying that in Vanity Fair and that's a very strong thing to
say and I think it's very interesting that instead of you know be being
embarrassed or anything that these pictures were
shown you expressed anger not only at
whoever hacked and posted these but anybody who is just going
to look at it thinking well it's posted everybody else is looking so why can't you.
You said they were guilty
too. Can you talk about deciding how to frame your feelings
about the hack of your photos.
I wasn't the first victim of that you know there have been hacks like that going
on for years and I have never once ever looked at a
photo of a naked person's body without their permission. I think that that's
a disgusting thing to do. It's unthinkable I would never do those
acts have happened for years
and. I would feel so creepy looking
at someone's naked body without their
permission and you know when it happened to me I wasn't embarrassed.
I was it was I was in a long distance relationship for four and a half
years and even if I wasn't in a long distance relationship it wouldn't matter it was my body with
my private email and I had the freedom to do what I wanted and
I was I was I was and I
was angry hackers are hackers. And hackers are gross
disgusting perverts and what they did was wrong
and that goes without saying
but the idea that.
It's when something becomes popular all of a sudden it's now
OK it's just shocking how it's not personal to people anymore. That's
why people can say whatever they want to me and in the news or are they can hear me
say one thing about me not liking popcorn and then judge my entire personality it's like assoon as your celebrity.
It's so impersonal. But those pictures were incredibly personal to me and my naked body.
I haven't shown on camera I haven't done anything you know by
choice of my body and I
felt angry at websites. Re posting them.
And I can't really describe to you the feeling
that took a very long time to go away wondering at any point. Who's just passing my
body around has got a picture of my body on their phone and is at a barbecue and looking at them
or who's It's it was an unshakable really really
awful feeling that after it healed a little bit made me
incredibly angry.
So you're involved with two projects now that I'm very excited about One is you working on a project
with Amy Schumer and the others. You're going to play Lindsay a
Dario the Great. New York Times were Fatah. For who wrote a
terrific memoir about her experiences in war
zones. So tell us a little bit
about one of those projects before we wrap
up. I have to choose.
Well why don't we go with the Amy Schumer because I think that's more of
a wild card I think because I'm more involved in that one
so I have no idea what that project is.
Amy Schumer and Jim Jim are sister and I finished the script about
a week ago. It's a
comedy and we really really love it it's just
now starting to get passed around are they going to make it you know Amy I've never seen the sight of
her before this character that she's going to be playing nobody seen the care and the character that I'm going to be
playing as a new side of
me and it was incredibly fun to develop and
the two of them being sisters Kaminey. That get along like I said things I've never
seen before and being and incredible writers has
brought such a harmonious unbelievable wonderful
relationship to the screen. You know that helped us develop these characters so kind of quickly
and thoroughly. I'm really excited about
that morning if it's particularly fulfilling for you
to work with Amy and Kim Schumer because so much of
their writing has a kind of agenda or awareness to
it a kind of feminist and these are things that obviously rising to the surface
in
your concerns about you know pay equality about nude
photos about
how women are perceived Of course you're doing it as a
comedy and not as like a speech.
Yeah you know you and I both
of our boys. You mean they're both share in the cam and I
all kind of share
similar. Politics
and you know and they're very early on there isn't a smartest people I've ever met in
my entire life Amy so incredibly observant people I mean even my dog
she can imitate my dog perfectly. She's a very brilliant
woman and yeah and we we did we did it we didn't the comedy
it's not very broad.
It's it's got some feeling in
it when I look forward to seeing it. Thank you so much for talking with us
I've really enjoyed it. Thank you thank you so
much Jennifer Lawrence stars in the new film joy and in the fourth and
final installment of The Hunger Games. Tomorrow on FRESH AIR.
What is it to be human.
What is it to be alive.
The new movie anomalies about loneliness and disconnection is told through
stop motion animation using puppets and miniature
sets but it looks oddly authentic. I'll talk with the film's directors Charlie Kaufman
and did Johnson Kaufman also wrote anomalies as well as the films Being John
Malkovich adaptation and the Eternal Sunshine Of The Spotless Mind. I hope you'll
join us.
With
FRESH AIR's executive producer is Danny Miller. Our senior producer today is Sam Briger
our technical director and engineers are due Bentham Dorothy Ferebee is our administrative
assistant Our associate producer for online media is Molly C.V. Nestor John
Myers directed the show. I'm Terry Gross
spoke
with bank.